E aí
[Música]
o Olá meu nome é Carlos O biólogo
escritor do primeiro livro infantil de
biologia sobre diversidade enquanto o
estava escrevendo e pensando que eu
poderia falar aqui eu fiz algumas alguns
questionamento primeiro como quando ir
porque eu comecei eu entendi que eu
poderia me referir alguma homossexual
como na verdade na minhas memórias
mais antigas é eu posso ter aprendido na
escola talvez eu lembro de ver colegas
chamando outros meninos de ou até
mesmo meninas de não sair de piranha e
vou
escutando do aluno se referindo a outros
com burros ou antes mas ao mesmo tempo
que eu lembro disso eu também lembro que
era presente em casa na rua na escola e
mesmo sendo frequente esses termos em
nenhum momento nenhum professor chegou
repreendeu até mesmo explicou o motivo
qual que são os argumentos biológicos
se assemelha a um alguém que é
homossexual
um dos termos mais presentes sem dúvidas
é o burro e é algo que vem desde a
infância até a vida adulta
mas na verdade os burros são animais
Mega inteligente estão sempre Associados
Assim como as plantas a falta de
inteligência mas na verdade não existe
nenhum argumento ou explicação biológica
pra isso existe diversos estudos
científicos comprovando a inteligência
dos burros inclusive um cão nosso
bastante Eles colocaram um burro com
sete cavalos durante dias e perceberam
que no final os cavalos estavam seguindo
imitando burro mostrando que os burros
são muito mais inteligentes que os
cavalos essa fama veio porque em algum
momento eles eles se recusam a fazer
algo a fazer determinada ação mas não
pela ausência de inteligência mas sim
pela presença simplesmente eles não
querem já a anta tem um papel Ecológico
muito forte é o nosso maior mamífero
terrestre é
importantíssimo para os nativos daqui do
Brasil inclusive antigamente a Via
Láctea era conhecido como um caminho das
plantas e os animais abriram espaços na
na vegetação para os nativos andarem
pegar em comida que anos depois de virar
um rodovias Esses animais plantou
milhares de árvores por mês e mesmo
assim só Associados à falta de
inteligência já um é um termo que
me questionei bastante durante e depois
da minha graduação os estudos sobre o
comportamento homossexual e animais rola
o desde a década de 90 primeiro livro
científico alcançado foi 1999 nesse
livro O autor o biólogo listou 1.500
espécies de animais são comportamento
homossexual e comprovou científicamente
esse comportamento mas engraçada que o
não estava nessa primeira lista
o Porém desde a década de 90 esse termo
é utilizado para falar sobre alguém
homossexual então eu acredito que isso
esteja ligado não algo biológico sim
algo social porque o animal delicado tem
que ter jeito que a sociedade interpreta
como um feminino
e o engraçado aqui nessa lista o leão
está presente mas os leões são sempre
ligados a figuras masculinas forte rei
da selva
mas em nenhum momento me informaram que
eu poderia chamar alguém homossexual de
leão na onde
agora antes e depois percebemos que os
estudos estão muito mais evoluídos
em 2009 Saiu uma atualização desses
estudos e Vale lembrar que quando eu
falo de estudos artigos livros e
publicações científicas
e 2009 conseguiram comprovar que na
verdade o comportamento homossexual está
presente em todas as famílias de animais
em todas ou seja na família dos felinos
temos os leões e leopardos os gatos e
tende a ter um comportamento homossexual
obviamente a gente escolheu alguns
algumas famílias como os animais que
nunca fizeram sexo ou os animais que
estão afrodisíacas que vai lembrar que
no Reino Animal uma boa parte do nosso
animais hermafroditas como peixe palhaço
e todos os peixes palhaços nascem macho
e se precisarem acabam trocando esse
aqui segurando fêmea Vale lembrar também
que a fêmea dominante do grupo Então
sempre que falta uma fêmea e um macho
precisa trocar de sexo e vira uma fêmea
ou até mesmo para se reproduzir Mas uma
coisa legal que não é mal não existe
nenhum tipo de preconceito nenhum animal
discriminado pelo seu comportamento
assim com os seres humanos animais não
sei lá os outros com fim de reprodução
Esse é o comportamento homossexual está
lá por prazer para aliviar atrito criar
laços afetivos
plano dos leões é muito comum você jogar
e na internet fotos de leões é se
relacionando com leoas do lado
e também é muito comum sempre pinguim
zoológicos e até mesmo em habitat
natural criando filhotes abandonados
e como biólogo E também como ser humano
eu não consigo olhar para um animal e
falar que era um pecador ou que ele vai
para um lugar ruim depois que ele morra
eu não sei qual o poder que eu qualquer
um ser humano tem de olhar para algo e
falar isso não certo isso não é natural
já que está presente no reino animal
e antes de finalizar gosta de citar
alguns animais entre eles os leões já
falei algumas vezes mas também os
pinguins ontem joga na internet pinguins
gays aparecer milhares e milhares de
notícias sobre os animais
o Zoológico sem Aquarius um dos mais
famosos é o Steven o Magic do aquário de
Sydney na Austrália Os dois estão juntos
há muito tempo isso é legal porque
geralmente alguns pinguins trocam de
fêmea a cada Temporada mas essa ação não
é Vista em uma relação homossexual os
pinguins consumo criar laços afetivos e
ficarem juntos até o final da vida mesmo
em casais heterossexuais e toda a
temporada nesse trocam de fêmea
É engraçado porque esse mesmo pinguins o
Estive no médico Eles estavam tentando
chocar pedras pensando que era ovos e ao
mesmo tempo eles tentavam roubar ovos e
outros casais que não estavam
preocupados deixa o Carlos no mesmo ano
em 2018 uma fêmea acabam abandonando o
ovo e um dos funcionários do aquário
acabou doando ou se ovo no casal que foi
o primeiro é o ovo deles e eles
conseguiram chocar a Lara anos depois a
Lara também deu à luz a outro filhote e
assim levou o gene desses pinguins para
outros descendentes eo ponto de vista
evolutivo é muito importante esses
relacionamentos porque em habitat
natural a taxa de mortalidade de um
pinguim é muito alta então a gente
percebe que alguns casais estão
preocupados Apenas não se reproduzir
então nós acaba abandonando os filhotes
que provavelmente pode poderia ser morto
por uma horta e casais homossexuais que
são dispostos o pinguim acabam salvando
a vida dele e assim liberando mais genes
para espécie que esse Gene serão
passados para outras gerações outros
comportamentos homossexuais que é visto
no Reino Animal seria dos bisões e só se
relaciona com as fêmeas em reprodução no
restante do ano eles acabam procurando
outros machos Mas o comportamento
homossexual mais presente é no
chimpanzés-pigmeus eles compartilham
98,7 o DNA com seres humanos ele se
relacionam sexualmente por diversos
motivos para criar laços afetivos ele tá
brigas o engraçado aqui esse
comportamento é mais frequente assim que
venha
e durante a relação os machos costumam
machucar um pouco a fêmea então para
evitar esses machos elas acabam se
relacionando com outras fêmeas
diante tudo isso é só consigo chegar à
conclusão que nenhum animal vai sofrer
preconceito e pela sua forma de agir
pela sua forma de viver e que isso é
exclusivo da espécie humana algumas
pessoas usam o argumento que o
comportamento a relação homossexual na
algo natural que não existe na natureza
mas existe na natureza porque não existe
na natureza é tudo preconceito Já que é
um fenômeno social e não biológico E aí
[Música]
E aí